a woman is in custody this morning after
leading police on a wild chase to a
California neighborhood in a stolen RV
the RV weaved in and out of traffic at
high speed and suffered extensive damage
Jamie yuccas shows us how the chase
unfolded look at that you can see this
border hole but making wild turns out
here it was just after rush hour Tuesday
evening I cannot believe what is going
on
authorities in Santa Clarita chased a
stolen motor home with a huge gash
behind the wheel a female driver with
two dogs inside during the pursuit you
can see one dog leap from the moving RV
oh my god
somehow walking to safety the driver
maneuvered her way through several
streets and sped through intersections
slamming into cars whoa this woman's
vehicle was totaled after colliding with
the RV oh my god I was practically
pulling my hair out it's the most
craziest thing I ever seen I'm just like
whoa what's going on here a kaboom it
all came to a violent end whoa injuring
a driver in the process she jumped out
of the RV's one of her dogs running
behind her but didn't get far before
police tackled her in front of a home
charges that were looking at right now
would be felony hit-and-run felony
evading and also or investigating
driving under the influence at this time
at least three people were hurt all with
just minor injuries and officials say
both dogs are safe with animal control
for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles well you look
at that video guys you wonder how in the
world she thought she was gonna get away
with that no I don't think she did you
know but you know it's not only a
vehicle that's somebody's home right at
home at home then the dog said let's get
out of here very glad that nobody was
seriously hurt
the dogs are okay the dogs are okay